The thermite reaction which is the reaction
of aluminium and
iron oxide is used to make iron and because
aluminium has
much stronger bonds to oxygen than iron that
the reaction
produces an enormous amount of heat and you
can use this
for welding pieces of metals together.
So this is a thermite mixture, it is a mixture
of iron oxide and
aluminium powder and we are going to do some
redox
chemistry and we are going to generate some
molten iron
which will hopefully stream from the bottom
of the flower
pot. So here you can see the black particles
of the iron oxide
and the silver particles are the aluminium
powder. So we get
some heat on this and we start an instantaneous
redox
reaction so the aluminium and the iron oxide
swap oxygens
so the aluminium will become oxidised and
the iron will
become reduced hopefully we will generate
a lot of molten
iron which should come from the bottom of
the test tube …
of the flower pot.
Alright!
Right.
Now there is a story about students in Berkley
that some
students, or group of students, decided to
do a practical joke
on a tram of the sort that has one door where
you go in and
another when you go out. So a big group of
students queued
onto the tram and got into the front and there
were enough
of them so they could actually come out at
the end at the
other door and form a loop so they were just
going round
and round and round so the tram could not
leave because
they were just more and more people getting
on.
We’re going to run out of tape.
And while they were doing this, other students
went down
under the tram and set off two thermite reactions
and welded
the metal wheels of the tram to the steel
rails so that when
the tram tried to leave, when the students
eventually stopped
going round and round, it was firmly welded
to the tracks and
could not move at all.
It’s gone out.
Tell us about what is going on mate!
So instantly the thermite reaction starts
and you can see that
it’s so hot that it burnt a whole through
the bottom of that
terracotta flower pot. But if we go in close
now Brady, you
can see all that really quite nice molten
iron. Now that is so
hot that the iron itself has melted and it
has formed this
really quite big goo in the bottom on the
sand.
Do you encourage these sorts of practical
jokes?
No, no, no, no ,no, our students are far more
responsible.
So as soon as the fire work, or the sparkler,
hit the top of the
thermite reaction, in the top of here, it
started obviously,
instantaneous redox reaction. So this is where
the metals
were fighting for the oxygen, the aluminium
won that battle
and the aluminium came out of this reaction
as aluminium
oxide. The iron was reduced and we can see
that now in the
bottom which is really hot so I am not going
to get too close
but you can see all of this really, really
hot iron. The iron was
molten, it dribbled out through the bottom
of the flower pot
and it is now cooling.
It didn’t dribble out of the bottom of the
flower pot.
Well it smashed its way out of the flower
pot.
Well you can say that iron is in my blood,
it is in your blood
as well. It is iron that gives haemoglobin
the red pigment in
your blood, its red colour.
So the reaction we saw was about 5 minutes
ago and the iron
that was generated is still glowing red hot
and you can see it
has fused itself to the bottom half of the
flower pot, which it
broke in its tumultuous step forward.
It is an absolutely essential element to life,
except for crabs
which use copper but you will have to hear
about that later.
So iron is a really, really abundant metal
which is used in lots
and lots of structural material, so you get
to see lots of
pieces of iron around, some of the racking
and even in fact
some of these pieces of equipment have got
high iron
content. They have got other elements in them
to form alloys
like stainless steel.
I have an extremely long standing interest
in its chemistry
and in particular, I made one compound of
iron so called iron
tetracarbonyl which had 4 groups round it
and everybody had
expected that it would have a shape like one
of these. Shaped
with tetrahedron like that whereas, in fact,
it had a much
more irregular shape, the 4 groups were arranged
like this,
and so every since this, every time I hear
the word iron I get
quite excited.
So this is iron wire, ok, and as you can it
is a very small wire.
It is 0.2 in diameter and you can see the
shiny material
underneath is iron that has not undergone
oxidation so this is
where it has been protected from the oxygen
in the air now if
we look at the iron at the top we can see
that this looks really
familiar especially because it looks like
some of the rust which
we can see at the bottom of some of our cars.
So here is
some iron oxide on top of the iron.
The very first chemical experiment I did the
chemical reaction
was with iron and I think the same is true
for many
generations of school children. I heated up
iron and sulphur
together and made iron sulphide sort of blackish
solid but
then we put acid on it and got a terrible
smell of bad eggs
and this was my introduction to chemistry
and I really loved
it.